u.s president-elect joe biden has chosen
a retired general
as his defense secretary if approved by
the senate 67 year old lloyd austin
would become the first african american
to head the pentagon
i chose lloyd austin as my nominee for
secretary of defense because
he will do whatever it takes to defend
the american people
when the islamic state emerged as a
terrorist threat in iraq and syria
president obama and i turned to austin
who then led
u.s central command he designed and
executed the campaign that ultimately
beat back isis lloyd austin served under
the obama administration leading u.s
central command he was the main
military architect of the u.s laird
offensive against islamic state
in syria and iraq he was also the one
who candidly admitted the failure of a
million dollar training program in syria
back in 2015 it was shut down after
producing just some
five trained fighters instead of the
several thousand that have been planned
can you tell us what the total number of
trained fighters remains
uh it's a small number and uh
the ones that are in the fight is uh is
is we're talking four four or five is it
still
the goal to have about 12 000 of them
there is that still the goal what's the
expectation then for them
uh at the pace we're going we won't uh
won't reach the uh
the goal that we had initially
established for ourselves
but but but the uh the overall goal is
to make sure that we have enough mass
uh to be able to get work done on the
ground meanwhile a potential stumbling
block for austin lloyd's candidacy is
the fact
he only retired four years ago u.s law
states an officer must have left the
service at least seven years
prior to becoming secretary of defense
senior research fellow at the global
policy institute george samueli
thinks exceptions will be made to the
rules
general mattis uh who became trump's uh
defense secretary also had to
overcome this uh hurdle and he overcame
it without too much difficulty
now of course there were senators at the
time we said that this is just a one-off
we're not going to do this again uh
you know we really mean it this time but
we don't have to take this very
seriously
so having said all that about uh matters
they're not likely to turn around
and make difficulties for
austin particularly as you know be
honest about it i mean he's
also uh would be the first uh black man
who would be head of the
pentagon so i don't think anyone's going
to want to put any hurdles in his way